well for one thing here to present the
award for the Best Supporting Actress is
an oscar-winning actor from Ben Hur last
year's sleeper here is Gary's mr. Hugh
Griffith
thank you ladies and gentlemen I am no
sleeper but as I was in England when you
kindly gave me the award last year may I
take this opportunity to thank you for
the honour now
[Applause]
but I know of course I would have been
here as fast as an astronaut could carry
me but it is rather a long way to come
from stratford-upon-avon where to Los
Angeles on a five to one chance
may I please apologize for my uncertain
appearance but I am still mutinying
on the bounty and I have two stubble and
to it again tomorrow and now it is my
privilege to say that the nominees for
Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role
ah the Glynis John's for the sundowners
Shirley Jones for Elmer Gantry Shirley
Knight for the dark at the top of the
stairs and Janet Leigh for psycho and
Mary your door Sons and Lovers these
times these lovely hi and the chosen of
these ism
[Music]
miss Shirley Joe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much I can only think
that I wouldn't be standing here tonight
accepting this Oscar it weren't for
another Oscar Hammerstein and mr.
Richard Rodgers and also for the belief
mr. Burt Lancaster mr. Richard Brooks
and mr. Bernie Smith having me and
allowing me to play the part of Lulu
Baines and Elmer Gantry
this is the proudest moment of my career
because of them thank you all
[Music]
we wish people get around you know
[Music]